foreign
let's go to Alex in Nashville Tennessee
right down the street what's up Alex
yeah I can hear you loud and clear I can
hear you even louder and clearer I'm a
one-upper I guess I don't know why I
just said that what's up man
um well frankly I am not okay doc that's
why I'm calling you well I'm glad you
called man let's figure it out what's up
so uh just to let you know um disclaimer
basically I'm not here to talk about how
wrong my life is we both have issues
that we need to deal with um okay I'll
offer to beat some pieces and the more
years I spend with my wife the more I
understand how to care for it
um that's why I'm here that's why I want
to get to the bottom of this let's do it
okay so
um I've been
a little bit background about myself
I've been sexually abused when I was
about nine years old I just was at
school I have plenty of babysitters I
have no clue that I was drunk to sleep
but sometimes
um but now I know and I suffer from
uncontrollable sexual thoughts uh fear
doubt broken self-esteem there'll be
some days when I come home I'll be fine
and some days I'll be just terrible
terrible
um if it wasn't for my family though
like later on in the days I probably
would have been a psychiatric Facility
by now so have you have you received
Mental Health Care over the years
uh not necessarily I went to a counselor
here and there but
um it it always backlashes uh with uh
with my current uh marriage uh either we
we still have things to figure out and
I'm trying to figure out where to go
from here have you taken the aces score
the aces test I have not yet okay I want
you to do that when we right when we get
off the phone it's the adverse childhood
experiences inventory and uh our survey
and I want you to take is 10 questions
it'll take you five minutes
okay
my guess is just based on what you told
me your score is probably somewhere
between six and eight if if maybe not a
little bit higher
a score a score over a four has been
demonstrated to shorten lifespan
hello if undealt with and here's why
okay
it sets your body off on high alert 24 7
365 and our bodies aren't designed to go
24 7 365.
and so it slowly Cascades through
everything okay so I'm telling you that
because
um
just listening to your story you sound
like a
pretty great guy whose car is redlining
and has been since he was nine years old
yeah
is that fair
yeah that sounds about right okay all
right so we won't harp on that because
that's not why you're calling so tell me
about your marriage ma'am
uh so
um so my wife has broken parents
um they never gave her love they never
uh spent time with her uh never
understood her uh they still uh treat
her as a child you know today
um her father was a workaholic mother
was a stay-at-home mom
she will actually take care of her
animals instead of her child and that's
just very very depressing uh but now the
anger and regret and all those things
are showing in the relationship and
um it's very hard because you know like
I'm a very passive man I don't really
like conflict I don't love conflict and
I I'm the kind of person to just leave
the situation rather than to fight in
the situation
um and uh
most of the time when we come to a
disagreement it just becomes very like
you know yelling anger shouting and
sometimes I just wonder why you know
like what did I do
um and it's always about what did I do
and how can I make it better uh and it
has been difficult since our marriage um
oh yeah so I'm gonna
um
I can tell that fragile isn't the right
word but I can tell that there's you've
got deep pain okay
and some of the things that I normally
this conversation with you had just said
what you said and we were in a
counseling relationship it would take a
lot longer to get there because I would
need your body to understand that I'm
safe okay because we only have a few
minutes on a phone call I'm gonna be a
little more direct than I normally would
okay yeah so I want if you if you feel
your body starting to shut down I want
you to stay with me the best you can
okay okay I'm on I'm on your team okay
okay so my first thing I want you to
hold in this and I want you to hold it
in your hand because you probably never
held it before
people who have been sexually abused
often carry deep deep shame
okay
people who carry deep shame often not
always but often find themselves as
adults
as peacekeepers as making sure everybody
else is okay
and I want you to think of the
peacekeeping role the you instantly go
to the mirror and say what did I do how
can I make this better I'm so sorry that
you're hurting I'm so sorry that you're
mad I'm so sorry that you're loud how
can I fix this how can I fix this
I want you to think of that as a as a
selfish Act
and not as a judgment I just want you to
be curious about it
because maybe your wife's response has
absolutely nothing to do with you
and when you try to go fix something
that's spinning around inside of her
it creates tension and chaos and
conflict here's what here's what I'm
back out your body has just a couple of
ways to respond to threats fighting and
fleeing are two of the main ones or
freezing
so think of the same issue
you have a tiger that's been chasing you
your whole life which is shame from
sexual abuse
and probably parents who said hey don't
tell anybody or friends who you kept
secrets from and all the relational
damage that comes out of that stuff
and your wife has a dragons that have
been chasing her forever and in fact
those dragons are still real they're
still right in front of her
in that situation your body chooses to
flee her body chooses to fight
but the underlying
reality is the same
see what I'm saying yeah yeah
and then that that that that lands in
your living room
and you're trying to solve something
that she doesn't want you to solve but
she wants to blame you for something
that you can't have no right it just
gets in this weird figure eight dance
yeah
does that sound right yeah something's
about right now okay so I'm getting a
sense that you are being very generous
when you describe your wife as getting
mad at you
tell me how she expresses herself to you
yeah of course I mean um very uh it's
kind of a rare situation to be in I mean
like
you have spent your whole life defending
other people
okay
be honest about it yeah I will my
promise to you is I will not talk about
about your wife okay okay I won't do
that okay
um but you've got to be honest with me
okay how does she treat you yeah well
um
not good I mean that in some cases where
I try even fleeing doesn't really help
it and sometimes makes it worse right
there will be I mean there were a couple
times where you know the police were
involved and um
screaming she threatening
I was in the vehicle she was driving and
it it got pretty hectic she was driving
records recklessly and it was it was
pretty bad but um
uh yeah so
at that time I had to find help and the
help that I got was uh uh it was good
but at the same time it was pretty tense
uh after that because I was away for a
while
uh we were doing marriage counseling but
so hold on you're speaking kind of in
code did you move out for a while
I did move out for a while listen to me
I believe it was for a few weeks okay
that's not sure that was the right thing
to do and I'm proud of you
okay
it's the right thing to do
I'm very proud of you oh it felt wrong
though I know I know I know
I know Shame Shame deep deep deep
unaddressed shame creates these
imaginary duties that we have to
everybody else in the world and then we
can't fulfill these duties that aren't
even real we then our bodies beat us up
for not being able to solve them
okay
um and I want you to think about this
she has parents that said treat her like
a child still those type of parents
withhold love if the performance by the
kid isn't up to par
so if she doesn't do whatever they say
in the right way she says it regardless
of what it is they ignore her they shun
her they don't invite her they say well
then we're not going out to dinner they
then you can't whatever
and so you have to understand her core
wound the thing deep inside of her is
this person in front of me who says they
love me is gonna leave
um and yeah what your body tells you is
if you get too close to somebody you're
gonna get abused again
and so when somebody comes close to you
you bolt and it's the right thing for
your body and her body screams he's
leaving again and then she goes to war
to which makes you go I gotta get super
the hell out of here and so you see how
each person's trauma is just playing
right into the other ones yeah the only
way this gets healed is one of you has
the courage to turn and stand it stare
it down
and that's what you did that's what
you're doing
what you're doing is really hard
yeah
and I'm super proud of you
thank you doctor it's hard okay now how
can I help you is there a particular
situation or what are you thinking
through what's like uh what's a a thing
that's going on
Okay so
um I just want to
understand how not to uh lash out her
because lately after coming back
um it has gotten better in some cases
but there tends to be that one time
throughout the year a few times
throughout the year where you know we
get into a big argument yes and I'm
starting to be less and less flighty and
more about fighting not a boy and I
don't I don't like that I know you don't
like it I don't want to go there but you
have to you have to you have to you have
to you have to I know you don't want to
everything in your body says run
but your heart says I love her I'm in
this marriage she's hurting I'm hurting
I'm standing my ground
okay
so how do I so basically I guess my
question is how do I make
um how do I make the arguments less
exposure how do how am I able to control
my feelings from getting in the way to
having a actual adult conversation
that's an um that the fact that you're
asking that question tells me you're
wise beyond your years and if every
person in a romantic relationship in the
world would ask that question the world
would change overnight
okay here I'm going to give you a couple
of words that I want you to put in your
back pocket okay and when this call
comes out and and uh I want you to take
it I want you to take a piece of paper
and write down what I'm what I'm saying
okay okay
the first thing is these conversations
have to be done offline
meaning you can't just try to and get
you can't just practice shooting a
basketball when the game is in the
middle of a playoff game
you got to spend time intentional time
at practice for years before the
playoffs because the playoffs have super
heightened tension there's a lot of
people watching there's a lot on the
line here and so I want you and your
wife to step out and and be honest with
each other your childhood sucked
and then you can look across the table
and say your childhood suck too
and the Beautiful Thing
is that you all get to choose what
happens next
and so often the exercise of let's take
all money off the table let's take all
the our past abuse off the table let's
take our parents having to come over for
Thanksgiving off the table let's take it
off the table
what do we want our one wild Reckless
crazy marriage to look like
it could be anything we want where do we
want to live what old jobs do you want
to have
some fun with that
and you know the things that she loves
whether it's a great meal or flowers or
a weekend getaway whatever it is make it
happen okay
the goal here is to change the
environment and to sit down and say okay
let's create a new picture that we can
both work towards because right now both
of y'all have been running from dragons
and you'll keep crashing into each other
let's go together to something all right
so yeah we're gonna create a new picture
a really high definition picture very
clear we want to live in this place in a
house that looks like this and here's a
the number two
how do you want the house to feel when
you walk in after work
and what we're looking for here is warm
and quiet or hilarious and loud and safe
and silly
okay
yeah and what we're going to try to do
is we're going to try to create that for
the other person
yeah so what I like when I walk in
sounds like a dream it does right but
here's the thing here's here's the
number three and this is the big one I
want you to Circle and highlight
y'all have never done this before and
you've never even seen it done
it feels like uh it feels like a Harry
Potter episode like a fantasy it's like
it's not real
and so you're gonna have to practice it
and that means you're gonna screw up a
lot
Steph Curry misses shots in practice a
lot of them but he keeps taking him so
that in a game he'll make him
and so what this means is
y'all are gonna go say okay here's what
practicing looks like
when you start yelling
I am choosing to hear that is that
you're done with a conversation I I
choose to not be yelled at so if you
yell you're telling me that you don't
want to engage right now and I'm gonna
head out
and if you want me to stay
then you are going to have to talk to me
with dignity and respect
in a quiet way
and that she gets to tell you
every time you run when I get scared or
I get loud my body feels like I'm being
abandoned again
and so when I get fired up and you feel
me tense
I need you to turn and stay in your
ground
I need you to reach up with both hands
and hold my hands and say I'm not going
anywhere I love you
see what I'm saying yeah what we're
doing here is we're asking the other
person when in a calm situation over
lunch over a breakfast we're in a
romantic place we're hanging out
whatever we're in a waffle house I don't
care where you are
how can I best love you
when your mom or dad says something that
just sets you off
how can I best love you when you have
super over sexualized thoughts
and you're feeling a lot of Shame
how can I best love you
and let's teach each other and give each
other that language you see what I'm
saying yeah I do yeah does this just
sound I mean does it sound like a like
insane or does it sound like wow this is
amazing
uh I mean it sounds possible it sounds
possible okay the third one being the
most probably the hardest but of course
it sounds like it's possible but you see
how it's all a progression so we're
gonna do the easy thing which is what
kind of house we want to live in what
town if we could live in any Town what
would it look like
and we're going to slowly get back to
you get home from an exhausting day at
work and your mom's been screaming at
you on the phone and you walk in the
door how can I best love you then
and so we're gonna we're gonna go from
easy which is I want a five bedroom
house with three pools and a tiger in
the backyard or whatever all the way to
stuff we've never seen before which is I
just need you to hold me
for two minutes and please don't ask me
any questions
I just need to feel safe right we're
gonna get that granular and then we're
gonna practice it and you're gonna
forget she's gonna come in blowing and
going ah and you're just gonna disappear
and as you're running away You're Gonna
Go
oh no no no no I gotta turn this I gotta
turn I gotta turn I gotta turn and your
body's gonna say get out of here and
you're gonna say I love her I'm heading
back in
or she's gonna come screaming at you
trying to smash something or say I'm
gonna crash this car I'm gonna crash
this car and at the stoplight you're
gonna get out and you're gonna say I
love you
and I'm choosing to walk away right now
when you walk away
but y'all have already discussed that
hey if you choose this I'm choosing this
I see and let me tell you this other
thing that you don't want to hear okay
mm-hmm
for the sake of you my friend Alex my
neighbor here in town
for the sake of your marriage
you're gonna have to go see a trauma
counselor
and say for the first time I was
sexually abused and I was a kid my
family did not respond that well
and I'm ready to get I'm ready to seek
healing
yeah okay you have to do that
yeah
and what my promise is is if you get
with a good trauma therapist here in
Nashville there's some incredible
therapists here in town if you get into
C1 it's gonna be expensive it's gonna
take a while and that's okay yeah
yeah at the end of it my question would
be like how how many times do I have to
go in and like like what am I supposed
to be doing now I guess make the phone
call and just trust the process
okay trust the process and when you get
there ask that question say I don't
understand how this whole thing works I
think this is weird I think just talking
to you is dumb it's gonna be a waste of
my time a therapist can handle that
they're professional that's their job
okay be honest with them
but here's what we're going for we're
going for that memory that shame that
immediately spins your body up your body
spends all day coming up with these
these um
looping thoughts trying to get a hold of
it these sexualized thoughts these
obsessive behaviors these I mean these
obsessive thoughts these compulsive
behaviors your brain is working all the
time trying to catch up ketchup ketchup
ketchup
what trauma therapy is going to do for
you is you're going to wake up and one
of these thoughts is gonna lightning
bolt into your mind and your body's not
going to take off on you
you're not going to feel like you're at
War your heart's not gonna be racing
really fast you're not gonna look around
the room to see if your wife's pissed
off and her body is gonna sense that
your body's calm
and so your energy your shame response
your response to abuse from 20 years ago
that your body's still electrified from
your sympathetic nervous system is still
Fire and Fire and Fire and Fire and her
body's not going to feel that energy and
start responding
and she's gonna have to have the courage
to tell her parents you don't get a vote
anymore I'm a grown woman
if y'all are going to tell me what to do
and treat me like a kid I'm hanging up
the phone
you don't get to talk to me like that
and if they're paying some of your bills
you all get to decide we're our sanity
and our maturity in our adulthood isn't
worth their money whatever the thing is
right
all this is gonna be about establishing
boundaries and yada yada all these
things are important but first we're
going to start with you and me are in
this together
you and me are in this together what do
we want this thing to look like and I'm
going first I call the counselor I'm
going to get well whatever it takes I'm
worth it and you're worth it and we are
worth it
Alex thank you so much for the call stay
on the line I'm going to send you a copy
of own your past change your future in
fact I'm gonna send you two one for you
and one for your wife and I want you all
to go through them together
and then come visit us in the studios if
you ever want to run downtown and hang
out I'd love to meet you in person
appreciate your courage man